everybody ready
i'll go ahead and spell them say and
spell my name
my name is carlos hank
c-a-r-l-o-s-h-a-n-k
good afternoon captain hank the las
vegas metropolitan police department
office of internal oversight
i'm here today to brief you on the
preliminary details of officer involved
shooting number 10
in lvmpd's jurisdiction in 2021
on
today at 11 27 a.m
officers responded to a robbery call in
the northwest area of town
through their investigation they
determined that a suspect had committed
or attempted multiple robberies to
include a bank
officers tracked that suspect to the
area of cheyenne and decatur
excuse me cheyenne and tenea and
attempted a car stop
at that time the suspect exited the
vehicle and produced a handgun
officers drew their weapons
fired at the suspect striking him
officers then rendered aid to the
suspect and requested medical attention
medical personnel transported the
suspect to a local hospital
where unfortunately he was pronounced
deceased
these are the preliminary details as we
know them at this time the member of
executive staff will come before you and
provide additional details within 72
hours
thank you
any questions yes
is there anything you can say to that
about
uh there's been rumors of a possible
bank robbery or something like into that
can you see anything about that there
was a bank robbery and we are an
investor we are we do have units there
investigating it and uh and it is
connected to this particular event yes
were there other people involved in that
robbery investigation or was it just one
person
in the are you talking about was the
person that we that we
were in the ois with was there
additional personnel
additional people at this time
the only person we know of that's
involved is the person that we have uh
that we have
that i i don't know of that information
and these are preliminary details that
can change
are you able to say which hospital he
was transported to no i cannot i don't
have that information unfortunately
i just know there's a local bank
in the in the area around here
can you give any details about the
person who
has now died
any information about them age
unfortunately i don't have that
information at this time this is a very
complex investigation because it
involved multiple scenes and we just
don't have that information at this time
i thank you all for the for the
questions and i appreciate your patience